[Music]
we say welcome to ear biscuits is that
what we say for the freestyle
uh some reason welcome to ear biscuits
yeah
it's like yeah it's like welcome the
first word because that seems really odd
to me right now
you're really fresh man what do you
think it should be now that you're back
from your solo trip
change it greetings greetings okay do it
greetings that's it greetings and
welcome to ear biscuits
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time i'm
rhett
and i'm link this week at the round
table of dim lighting
i'm gonna talk about the trip that i am
fresh off of i got home last night
from six days of
van life boom docking in the middle of
nowhere camping just me
and my wife some national parks
a lot of utah probably mormons i didn't
know
yeah you know yeah just i didn't i
didn't statistically
just statistically speaking right
probably ran into a few mormons
mm-hmm uh i didn't i didn't uh i didn't
run over him but i didn't run into
anybody like there were no good there
were no accidents
but i will say on the last night
something happened to us that i just
have to i want to tell you the whole
story
it it it just
i was so scared okay i'll just say that
we
chrissy and i both got really scared
[Music]
and it was just a strange story and i
just want to tell the whole thing
and that's why i texted you this morning
i was like hey i think
if we're coming in here to record first
thing fresh off our trips i think i've
got
with everything i want to share with you
i've got a whole episode yeah if it's
okay for you to then have another
episode and i don't care who goes first
right and so today we're going to hear
about your trip
yeah next time we'll hear about my trip
i will give you just a short preview
all right which incidentally includes me
being scared
i was thinking dude i was thinking about
you a lot um i was like i wonder
okay we'll get into it so uh okay but it
also
so it also includes um
an update on
the conversation argument slash
debate am i a competitive person that we
turn into an entire episode
uh i had some time to think about that
and i have sort of uh
i have some perspective on that i
definitely do not want that
just trust me it will not be a majority
or even a significant part of the
episode it's just an update
are you saying this to me so i'm not
scared no i'm saying it to to them
i'm saying it to all the people who some
people enjoyed that conversation
and some people didn't you know i saw
some people like this is the first one
i've never i did i just had to quit
listening to
yeah so and i totally get that because
it felt like
it was it was some people don't don't
want to hear like it turned into a
debate
yeah so i have just an update on some
perspective that kind of came to me in
the desert
uh and also just a summary of my trip
and some other things that happened but
let's hear about yours but even right at
the beginning of this when you
you know you said greetings and you had
a different voice
well yeah is that is that a new red
voice i was
playing into okay are we gonna are we
gonna include
sure the part that we i think we did
yeah they heard it yeah i basically
forgot how
ear biscuits started i mean like i
literally forgot how
i do have this feeling first of all i'm
not totally awake
i should have i i had a coffee i should
have had a second coffee i do feel like
i've
i need a day like
the experience that i had and the
christian i had that i share is going to
be very raw because i haven't
i haven't fully assimilated back into
life i think that's what
are you feeling that a little bit and i
got home last night i got home last
night later even later than you did like
i came home
basically as it but the sun was going
down six days of camping
turns out that's a long time and i was
not alone
i mean i i really want to hear your
experience
and i've imagined a lot of that and
we're going to record mine tomorrow
so just one day apart so it'll still be
it'll be fresh it'll still be fresh for
me
okay okay um well
just to give an overview of my trip
we ended up decide deciding we were
let's say we drove past vegas
and when we when we stopped in vegas we
we got something to eat i mean we just
ate in the car that's the great thing
about this sprinter van is that
what did you eat well we we were going
to go through the raisin cans oh crap
raising canes in vegas yesterday
no you didn't yes hold on you ate a
raisin canes in vegas yesterday no two
days ago i'm sorry i ate at raising cane
when we were coming back through i saw
the sign i was like oh raising content
i gotta try this out everybody post
malone's into it yeah
and so i got it in my car well we were
trying to eat there on the way and then
i the sprinter ram would not go through
the drive-through so
we had raising canes i went through went
to
because i had my rooftop tent on i
thought about this there was no
no overhang so we went to different ones
i went to the one on the east side of
vegas
um i can't say which one i went to
because as soon as i don't want to drive
too much traffic because i was coming
from the east coming back home
okay and there's more than two yeah and
as soon as i saw the sign i was like
well i'm going there
it's pretty good right i mean it's like
i would say it's like zach's piece but a
little better
uh my opinion was the chicken is good
chicken is great the fried sprinkle
fries
man horrible i thought the fries were
horrible
i'm comparing them to bojangles and
bojangle's fries
yeah dipping sauce was good and we'd
already had that that's the only thing
i've had
slaw bad slaw was bad yeah uh
tea good i got tea i didn't get the tea
maybe i should have they didn't have a
biscuit oh
texas toast oh the texas toast that was
good it was good yeah that and the
chicken tender
i highly recommend it so we start there
but we're eating in the van
we're we're peeing and pooping in the
van we're washing our hands in the van
there's a shower we could even shower in
the van but there's also a
hose off of the back of the van
where we ended up showering and because
it was the shower on the inside is so
small
so small and there's a toilet in it oh
yeah i told the toilet no
toilet toilet are you going to talk hot
water you're going to talk about the
pooping are you going to get into that
uh sure yeah because i'm going to get
into that that's
my trip as time allows totally different
we have to throw perspective
okay to my experience once i hear yours
because i would not say that's a
highlight or something that i plan on
talking about at length
but for me i'm always game to talk poop
if you want to go for me it will
not be an insignificant part of myself
okay okay okay i'll just add some two
cents at that point but until then
i'm just gonna say you know we stayed in
the van we you know we
we we got the five guys take out we took
it to the car
on the way back through is where we went
to a raising kings and we figured out we
could call them and they would bring it
out to us
yeah that's when curbside i saw that
sign um
and when we we kept going from vegas
from there we decided
i saw one of the scholar brothers
tweeted that they were at zion
and i was like i'm a direct message scar
bros you know haven't talked to them in
a while
but we're like you know they know who i
am
and uh i said i'm thinking about going
to zion but i'm concerned about the
crowds
you know the coveted regulations and
everything and i can't get on the
shuttle i have no shuttle reservation
and he said well
you should definitely go do a private
shuttle
you can pay there's one there's shuttle
companies that go in
you just get one of those and then you
get on a private shuttle they take you
right because
zion and we ended up doing that and he
said
we did the narrows hike you should
definitely do that i saw the pictures he
had like a walking stick and these
special
boots and he was he was like i was like
okay we're gonna we're gonna do this
based on just direct messaging this
tweet cause i was just to go to bryce
canyon
and skip it because less people go there
and it's less
regulated anybody can go in but i began
to understand when i got there
to zion i it's it's relatively small i
mean when you compare it like a yosemite
your small both been on your map yeah
it's it's um
it's this one canyon that
i mean the virgin river just cuts
through this thing and it almost doubles
back on itself and it makes these
like amphitheater areas and
to get up into that canyon you have to
be on a shuttle
so they just don't let cars go through
there because they would jam up the
whole thing right
and so that's why the shuttle thing is
so important
so we get up and we we
we made a reservation for 9 30 to be
picked up we go out there how far
how much ahead of time did you have to
call to make this reservation
uh it was noon i was it was noon the day
before
and they had a few spots open in on that
shuttle
and uh so we went the next morning we go
out there and
the shuttle takes you all the way
through to the back end of the park
where it's like
it it's a cul-de-sac basically like
a river made sheer wall like
thousands of foot tall like red rocked
mountain climber heaven type thing it's
i don't even want to try to explain it
you can look at the pictures and you
know it's like they always say until you
go you really can't appreciate it is it
better than yosemite
it's so much smaller and so much
different it's like going to an
attraction there's only a
you can really do it i mean you can
spend multiple days there and enjoy it
but i al i felt like we just did that
one day and we did the one
hike uh and i was like you know what
we're going to move on to bryce the next
day
we'll call it a travel day which is a
different national park
yeah so just to tell you about the
narrows hike
you're hiking in the river which is like
it's i mean the it has carved
these this deep chasm
yeah this is the one you see on
instagram yeah and it's
uh it's just absolutely amazing like
you know i can show you some of the
pictures but there's no after you hike
in a little ways
everyone's just getting in the in the
river and there's no trail anymore and
you're just hiking
in the river and it's usually
like shin deep sometimes it went to mid
thigh deep on me and it was
cold and i was like i was talking
i was trying to get christie like ready
for i was like you know what we're gonna
she's like we can turn back at any time
and this is before we get in the water
and i'm like
come on we got to do this what kind of
shoes did you have on i just had on our
we our quick dry low top
shoes we didn't wear our boots but these
people are the ones that we took to like
fiji
uh no not like water socks just like
hiking shoes but
low top i we didn't want to wear a high
top because they would get real soggy
at least that's what we thought i mean
people are renting like
these waterproof hiking boots with like
ankle support you really do need ankle
support and they give you a stick and
you're supposed to use that to stay up
but like
i you know i walked in the river so much
it was easy to walk over all these rocks
it was like
when we crossed the cape fear river
except the water was
clear for the most part and cold and
really cold
but you could turn your ankle and you
could fall down easily
but i think we gained confidence when we
saw like retirees
trudging through this thing and we were
wearing a mask there was a lot of people
uh going up this thing but it was a it
was a hike unlike anything else
and we go up there for a number of miles
and it's just it gets to a point where
it gets really narrow
i mean it could have been like 15 feet
apart like sheer
a thousand foot in the air it seemed
like and it was like
and you're just walking through up this
what i would call a stream it's not
really a river by that point
so it sounds like there could be a
problem if it was to flood
yes but you know they take all that into
account in terms of i guess they
they they had confidence that there
wasn't going to be a flash flood
right or they would have shut it down
and there were so many i mean even with
kova there was a lot of
there was a lot of people hiking there
but it was totally worth it
um the next day i'm gonna go through the
park stuff now because what i really
want to talk about is a camping
experience and then the story that
happened
okay so i mean that was a super cool
hike i definitely recommend that for
everybody like i was thinking the kids
would have loved it as
once they got over the cold of the water
your feet get numb and then this is
going to be though as warm as the water
gets you would think i would think so it
wasn't
it wasn't phased by being you know
it was it was like in the mid 80s uh
actually it was in the low 80s it was
like
un it was like perfect weather to be
there
right and then um so we camp that night
the next day
we took it we took like an easy day of
just camping
uh like getting going late but then we
drove to bryce
canyon which it was like
you wind your way up out of zion
and you go through
when these when the tunnel was built
through the mountain
it's like the longest tunnel in the
world at the time it was built in like
1920
and it was crazy you're like going
through the mountain on this how long
are we talking about
uh like i'm gonna know that
i don't know if it was the longest one
in the world it's got like 10 minutes to
get through it
i mean at least a mile oh yeah and we
can look it up
um i was driving i couldn't google i i
was like it's dark in here
but 10 minutes to go through yeah so
several miles
yeah i mean we were going pretty slow
we're probably going
oh we're going 30 miles an hour 25.
um anyway
you wind up out of there and then you
you drive for like a little over an hour
hour and a half and you get to bryce
which is a it's it's kind of like if
you've ever been to the grand canyon
you go in and it kind of feels the same
because you're in the woods and you go
to the edge of this
canyon you you walk to the rim of it and
then
it's all of these uh hoodoos is what
they're called like
uh you know if you make a sand castle
the type of sand castle people can make
on the beach where they like drip
sand and it like the sand just plop
plops on top of each other
it's like that except done by erosion
not by addition and they're
just like these these pinnacles of
sandstone stuff just everywhere and it's
like a magical
fairy land that you're walking down
through so we did a hike down through
there and
uh it's cool that it's so close and it
also was small so it felt like
i can see all of this in one day i could
hang out for a couple of days and really
appreciate it but
i can also move on knowing that i got an
idea what this national park is like and
i've done one of the more
one of the most famous trails so we did
that
uh the next day camp that night and then
we drove back
down just to get closer to home we drove
down to
uh the other side of vegas like well on
this side of vegas there's a place
called red rocks
national preservation
area and it's like so we
we we looked at all that there's like a
cool scenic drive
is right outside of like the mountains
you see
on 15 from on the main highway to the
uh to the west of vegas like that
mountain range there is like this red
rock
you have to get off of the interstate
yeah
well no but is it like because i i
yeah just yesterday i drove that and i
was kind of
i was like i'm trying to get home by a
reasonable time so i didn't stop at
anything yeah i didn't see
any signs for that i saw like the mojave
national preserve
yeah it's it's before that it's yeah
it's
right outside of vegas like literally if
you go west out of vegas there's like
these condos and like these
you know desert communities they build
up that are like really nice and then it
turns into nothing
and if you go if you go south around
the red rock that's where we camped the
last night and then
instead of coming back down into vegas
we went around
and skirted the edge of death valley it
actually said it was faster
from where we had camped the last night
where the story happened
how are you going to talk about camping
i asked you how hot it was
i picked that place because it wasn't it
wasn't the hottest night
but everywhere i picked it was just
trying to like escape the heat and
that's anything that might be that's why
i didn't camp
uh near vegas the last night yeah i was
like
it's gonna be like 105 during the day
and
that was the high like down at like
vegas level but then once you once you
got into that like
hilly rocky area that where we camped i
picked it because it was
it was probably like a high of 85 there
actually maybe 90 but then
so it wasn't it wasn't uncomfortable at
night um
so we went there and then we we skirted
the edge of death valley
we saw hot springs because i saw a sign
took like a two minute detour
dumped our our crap and our
our water like literally you gotta i
gotta
well we'll talk about the crap later
well hot springs uh
tacopa it's just some little town but it
was just some guy at a booth
and then behind his booth was like a
men's
shack and a women's shack and showers
and then i he let me look at it it was
just like a pool like a
actually you know it wasn't rustic in
any way and i didn't have time to get in
i was just curious
i need to dump my crap and get out of
there and then we came home you mean he
had felt they had pumped the water into
like a tub yeah
yeah the water flowed in there was a hot
water pool like it looked like a
big rectangular pool like 15 people
could get in but nobody was in it
and then there was a cold pool on the
other side in another room
and you had to be nude and and it wasn't
co-ed
so you only do nudifis co-ed sorry
that's right
all right that's that's right
you know what i don't do either one on
its own it's got to be both
but the the main experience that i'm
taking away
about that by the way okay yeah i know
you were aiming for hot springs so i
won't hear about that my main takeaway
was not
the beauty of these parks but it was the
experience camping so that's what i want
to spend the most time
talking about and then telling you the
story about how we got freaked out
night before last our last night there
camping
um so i'll get into all that but first
let's promote some stuff you know what
uh
we made a lot of merch when we wrote our
book the lost causes
and we don't regret it you sounded like
you regretted it a lot
no i'm just saying and it's going to be
gone forever
and so it's in the last chance section
of the mythical.com store
so if you want anything like the
sweatshirt that link has maybe gone
right now
or yeah i know i mean it's in the last
chance section we're recording this a
few weeks ahead of time it could be gone
but go over there
that whole last chance section doesn't
just have the bleak creek merch it's got
anything
that we're discontinuing and not
bringing back
for instance i'm drinking out of this
good luck with that mug
oh you know this doesn't exist anymore
you cannot
you can't buy this anymore can you i
don't think so you can't
buy this anymore because we make a
limited run of everything that we do
so we got to move on yeah got to keep
going so good luck with that
what lies ahead we have no way of
knowing but under our feet baby the
grass is growing
time to move on time to get going is
that a
tom petty song okay got it
mythical.com get your stuff last chance
before it's over
oh man i gotta shave immediately after
this
like i want itching yeah this is the
worst
phase and i took my razor camping i was
like
who's gonna sh who's gonna shave when
camping what kind of chump
shaves one can people who commit to
long-term camping
and also shaving shave they do shave
i think i would do that yeah i met
i met some people i mean several clean
shaven people oh yeah
who who were who were permanently as
christie calls them road travelers
yeah i mean like she could not remember
the word for a hitchhiker
no no he encountered this guy on a back
road who who he was just walking down
and i pulled over
i pulled over he had a huge beard oh
yeah and i was like do you need any help
and he had the the most paranoid guilty
look on his face like he just killed
someone
and he was like i don't need to help
kill anybody i do it alone
i was like okay and i was done i don't
know why i stopped and talked to you
yep did he if he didn't if he's not like
he was in the middle of nowhere
and he was walking and
using my instinct is just to keep going
like
let him eat the dust but i was i was
being very
altruistic and then i
got a little scared that is a good point
though because i i met a couple
uh just a young couple that was moving
they were in the process of trying to
move from new jersey to california
uh in a van oh okay and they were like
these fires started and so where we were
gonna go
is basically on fire right now so we're
kind of just hanging out this was in
nevada yeah uh and they had been on the
road for like three weeks and it was
completely clean shaving and i haven't
thought about that at all and he was not
the kind of man who can't grow a beard
i could see the potential for a beard i
think he was you know such a shaver
he he had his destination in mind and i
think it's psychological it's like you
know what for that guy
i'm i'm putting a lot on him but i think
you know his tie
to the to the civilized world is him
continuing to shave
and once he stopped shaving he was
giving up on his hope
of ever reconnecting with society on the
west coast where he was going to make a
life for himself
and uh presume his partner yeah and
hashtag van life
and they were uh they were like they
were in a
converted astro a four-wheel drive
no judgment and that had a pop-up thing
on it and
i could tell by the way that the
woman his companion yes was taking
pictures of like this hot spring that we
were at
and everything and waiting for the
sunset and like she went to the hot
spring and she moved
things around i was like this is a total
hashtag van life
and like they're getting these really
good pictures i can only imagine what
this instagram is going to look like
well our van was
everything was it had all the amenities
but the materials that they used to make
everything
were very rugged it felt like you could
just take a hose and hose everything off
because it's it's a rental and i mean
they touted how much they
rigorously cleaned the thing are you
saying between people using it you you
if you were to do your own deal you
would want like mahogany what do you
yeah the ones it wasn't picturesque
because you started to think about
hashtag van life is these people who put
stuff on instagram
and i was sitting in the back of the van
on our the day after zion when we were
like
we're just gonna take this day we're not
gonna we're not gonna rush off the
campsite we're gonna wake up we're gonna
eat breakfast we're gonna hang out here
hell we may even take a nap before lunch
time a late morning now
yeah which we did yeah
never been done before and then i was
like you know what seems almost
impossible before
yeah i know right the whole hanging
around in the morning
which for me ended up being the
highlight i'll talk about that
but never did it strike me that i should
take a morning to get back in the tent
and take a nap
like not even well this these are it's
different the back doors of the van are
open
this is a hashtag van life moment you
lay down in the in the bed
and then you stand up towards the cab at
the driver's seat and someone takes a
photo
through the back of the van at the
scenery did you take someone that you're
gonna post a hashtag fan live well
i said christy come in here and take a
picture of me i was laying on the bed
thinking about maybe taking a nap she
was outside reading a book and i was
like come in here
take a picture and so she she takes my
phone she comes right up to me i was
like no no no haven't you seen
that go back to the back to the kick to
the cab that asks people
want to shoot past me and then we tried
to do that and then i looked at the
pictures and i was like you know what
i'm not going to blame christy for this
yeah it's it's an art it's the decor
it's the
so many things have to line up for it to
be
hashtag able van life and let me tell
you it was not worth it
because that right there i think it
ruins the enjoyment it it
it it proved to me how much of a if you
if you get really good at it you can
probably do it quickly but it takes a
lot of practice to look like you're cool
out there when this woman
went live this woman went to the hot
spring she just
moved a bunch of stuff around the hot
spring and then
no but i was i i'll explain why but i
was very close to the hot spring
the thing that i didn't fully anticipate
i guess i could have known this but it's
one thing to say it it's another thing
it's kind of like going to a park you
can say how beautiful it is but until
you're there you really can't experience
it i think
in a similar way i could have known that
this camp
camping excursion would have been unlike
any other but i really didn't think it
through until it was happening
first of all me and christy the best of
my
recollection we've never gone camping
just the two of us yeah
ever me and jesse have never done it um
every time that i would go camping
i mean in college we would go and it was
it was also mission oriented
we're gonna go to this place so that we
can experience these things so that we
can do these
things and
uh whenever we would start going
off-roading
like when we first moved out here like
we did the death valley trips and stuff
like that
camping was kind of just the means to
bed down
in between doing more off-roading you
know
the most prevalent experience of camping
is bringing the kids and
there's so much logistics associated
with once you have
one two or three kids good gosh right
and
you know it's just definitely one two
minutes trying to keep everybody
straight and keep
everything together and somebody's all
everybody's got opinions and everybody's
on edge i didn't realize how
you know i came with a mentality of
this is not everything we talked about
in the last ear biscuit is not about
it's just about taking every day as it
comes and this
my desired outcome is quality time with
christy and then hopefully
that this is overall a great experience
that we can then do again
you know so within that context i
started to realize
i started to have thoughts like the
first night when we were camping
and you know setting up the camp was so
easy there was no tent to set up
there was no fire to start which is
illegal i just had that pro
propane tank and you just fire that up
cook some stuff you immediately turn it
off and on and like it doesn't spread
flames at all it's legal
but it makes it so simple i found myself
i found myself i found myself having
this
abundance of time headspace to think
and i actually had the thought
for the first time i'm starting to
connect with
nature like you hear people talking
about
how they go out in nature and like some
people say well you know i feel closest
to god when i'm in nature or
i just like to connect with the earth
and i was like
like you know hunters do that in their
own way
like you know where they don't want to
get so hard so hard they kill it
uh but it's this like primal thing like
farmers do it they get their hands dirty
they like have a relationship with the
earth
that they learn to speak its language
and to give to it
and benefit from it and i actually
started having these thoughts
you know just like a level of
appreciation for connection with nature
that on all of the campuses i've been
through
through they're just wanting a lot of
space for that
um and you know we're like setting up
our camp we're eating we're watching the
sun go down
it also helps and
i'm assuming this was your experience
because definitely my experience it also
helps
for me when you're not in an established
campground yes
i to me that like dispersed camping for
the win
that made all the difference in the
world in being able to even say for the
win
to feel like there's an opportunity to
connect
because when you're in this like okay
well there's this
especially when it's like a page if
you're in a campground campground and
there's a
there's a there's a building over there
that a person built that you can take a
crap in
yes that to me that just takes away from
it even if the scenery is beautiful
and also oh and there's another person
right there next to you and you can hear
their conversation
you can like hear their even if you
can't make out what they're saying you
can kind of just hear the
food and it's like okay that's part of
camping is what we thought and and we
have camped like totally isolated but
we've done it with other people
like when we went to death valley there
was nobody around in many of those
nights
except for the group but it was like
five trucks full of guys
so you still have that there's no
isolation but yeah definitely that first
night
we found this amazing campsite just
outside a
zion on
national forest land using the
ioverlander app
that was the app that worked best for me
i ended up using that yeah
we didn't have cell service but the spot
was so good
we were like all right we're going to
zion tomorrow we're going to come back
to the same spot
and enjoy it again because it's such a
good spot like we could see the sunset
well you know it was like a ravine right
there there were red rocks
i took a garmin
[Music]
satellite phone yeah not a sponsor i
think it was the in reach or something
like that
and so even when i didn't have cell
service i could text
jessie and it texts her and it's in it
and she gets the text on her phone
in a location and a link to my location
on the map oh that's cool
uh and there's and it's like a monthly
service that you can turn on and off
and i think it's like 30 bucks for the
month and then you just turn it off and
it's
stagnant while you're not using it
that's nice peace of mind because yeah
i i mean i was by myself yeah so i
definitely had to do that
um yeah so that isolation
it really creates so much more space
than i even anticipated and it was
it was just it was it was relaxing
and and so it gets dark you're hanging
out
and i turn off the actually i didn't
turn off the propane
fire yet we were like sitting around the
fire we were looking up and we were just
like
man look at the stars
oh yeah it was it's the time of year it
took me a while to figure out
why i mean it was totally clear the most
stars
i had ever seen except for that night
that we landed in fiji and it was dark
and we got on a boat
that had no lights on it and they took
us out to that island that we stayed at
for a week
and we looked up at the sky on this boat
which like
chris and i were talking about that and
they were like i can't believe we did
that like in the middle of the night it
felt like in the pitch dark we get on
this boat
and then we're just going out and
there's no lights on the boat it seemed
like
because we would look up and we saw so
many stars
and it it took me back there because
that that was the only time i'd seen as
many stars as we saw that night and i
turn off the
uh the fire and i turn off all the
lights on the uh
the van and
we just just craned our necks and just
just we watched the stars like we were
watching a movie
and that had and you can never happen
and you can see like
the the the bright like sort of like
cluster
stars beyond the stars i was like is
that the milky way
well you're in the milky way and then
yeah i convinced christy it was the
milky way and then we came home and
lily's like
dad you're in the milky way that she was
like those are nebulous
is what she said did she say nebulous no
she said uh
supernovas that's what she said like all
that
supernova is an event but this is just
more stars right you can see it was a
whole band across the sky like one
band of more stars right yeah
you know what like the milky way by the
time by the time
i record mine i'll i'll tell you what it
is i'll know definitively yeah i wanted
exactly because i saw
i didn't have because you don't see that
at all in los angeles you don't even
think it was
mesmerizing and i didn't you know
like i said we were just watching like a
movie and we were just it was a
highlight it was amazing
and then did you did you see um
we'll talk about aliens but um did you
see
when it's that clear and you and and you
have that big of an expanse
if you look for long enough you start
seeing shooting stars yes
we were both looking up and we saw the
same shooting star
and it was like whoa we just saw that so
like
seeing a shooting star together and just
talking about how
okay first of all a shooting star is not
a star it's not a star at all shooting
stars a meteor no shooting star is the
milky way
it's like just to see this to both see a
suit shooting star
to see this this meteor it's almost like
what's the movie where the serendipity
to share that fightful
american tale is that when you're both
looking at the same
yes it's just like that it's just like
that except red
christians next to each other is it five
or fifal five
five or five
and then you know we watched the stars
we had eaten it was time
it was time to you know to start bend
down for the night
and then i i realized and i had this
thought in the back of my head
but it's not the type of thing that i
wanted to say as part of my intention
and i wanted to i wanted to hold on
loosely because
you don't want to attach too many
expectations and you don't
you know a lot of things have to line up
for certain things
to happen i'm interested where you're
going with this but
that night it was like you know what
you're not trying to have a fourth kid
are you because you're not capable of
that
no that's not what this is about that's
exactly what this is about
i'm talking about getting into the van
and saying you know what
i brought some mail you brought some
mail i think we need to sort this mail
yeah right we should sort this mail the
back doors of this van are open
there's a nice space here where we can
lay out all the mail and sort it right
and this
hold on this is the first or the last
night this is the first night i'm about
to say uh hopefully this didn't wait
until the last night but i just figured
out this could happen
this is this is the first night and i i
knew it could happen but it
you know what can happen i just never
know i never know
you know a lot of things have to line up
to say you know what it's a good time to
sort the mail
and if you're making a lot of
adjustments to a place the last thing
you want to do
sometimes is sort the mail and you got
to have an internet connection so you
can look at the wikihow and know how to
do it again
and i remember how to distort the mail
and
i we just felt like for those of you who
didn't listen to that episode sorting
the mail is having sexual interest
that's for them to find out okay yeah so
we embark on sorting the mail
uh it turns out we have both brought
mail
that needed to be sorted uh that's
important both of you have to be sorted
right yeah you just can't be one person
right right yeah it's like it's very
selfish both people's
i mean if you both bring mail you should
both sort it yeah it should both be
sorted
did you sort hers first sort each
other's mail
because you should really store hers
first don't be one of those guys well
i mean it's like you if you if you want
to categorize your mail
then you like put it into stacks and
then you might sort some okay some of
your mails over here
some of the stacks i'm gonna sort summer
well
we sorted some of her mail sort of some
of my mail then sorted the rest of her
mail
and then sorted yeah yeah you don't want
to do all sorting
right you want to mix it up and then
just make sure you want to save a little
bit of my mail
to sort yeah last but the thing is is
once you've sorted your mail
you don't want to sort anymore that's
why that's why that's why the mail
the mail's mail is sorted blast yeah
yeah i was like it felt like
it felt like two teenagers like going
off into the woods in a van we never got
to do that and it's like and
we never got to go parking i mean not
that not that teenagers
even cared about their mail but you know
what i'm saying right i mean it felt
like teenagers sort
mail it was it was just a lot about mail
and then i started thinking
is this is the purpose of this van this
is a rental van
it's the purpose of this rental van so
that people can take it
and go off into the wilderness and sort
their mail that's why they wash it so
much are other people sorting their mail
right here
that's why they tell you we've really
really really rinsed it down i started
to get freaked out
of what i wasn't even done sorting in
the mail and i'm starting to get freaked
out about thinking about other people
sorting their mail well have you ever
been into a hotel and then i thought
about the hotel thing and i'm like but
it feels different because it's
tighter in here and there's i don't know
it just felt a little different okay
and then i started thinking you know
what you're overthinking this actually
continue to overthink it and you'll come
through the other side
here goes a lot of people want to sort
the mail
you know what i'm going camping i'm
going to bring all this mail on the
sword
were you were you talking about this out
loud or just know about it no
too smart for that that distracts from
but the point here you're not good at
doing two things at once so i can only
imagine that your mail sorting was
suffering significantly at this point
well that's not the only thing i had to
take a break for
i mean it was so i was so parched i had
to keep my water bottle
up by my pillow so that in the middle of
the night i could reach over i could
grab my water why don't you just sleep
in a camelback
and it's a good idea i do have one if
you just would sleep in a camel back
and you could put it on your front so
you don't accidentally sleep on your
stomach yeah i don't sleep it's a camel
front you should get
you should make a camel front that's i
or i could just run
a straw from my water bottle into my
mouth and not have to wear anything
because that's basically what i had a
tank of water and then it's going to
spill at one point we were
like we were sorting you know we were
doing a good job of sorting like at a
certain point it's like wow i really
know where everything goes now
now that you're 42. and then i look up
and i see my water bottle
and i grab it and i start drinking water
and then chrissy's like you can't take a
water what are you you're taking a water
break in the middle of
our mail sorting only link neal i was
like i'm so parched
like your nose yeah like my nose is
still running a little bit because it
was so
trying to moisten itself and like
everything got so dry
my mouth was so dry oh gosh yeah but i
started to feel better
before and yeah lesson learned but
i was so i started freaking about other
people sorting the mail then i realized
you know what
a lot of couples they they get out here
and like one of them done
one was like you know i didn't bring my
mail but the other one's like i didn't
bring my mail it's like again you both
need to bring
mail to be sorted if you
if if you really want this thing to work
out i think most people
one person will be thinking oh we're
going in this van i'm definitely
bringing mail
but both of them maybe not i think most
people
when they're packing everything and
they're like you know oh my gosh i know
i'm going to forget something
at that point even before they left on
their trip
they say you know what i ain't got room
for mail and they don't even bring it
so then i started to feel better i think
that broke in
that van so you're telling me that you
are trying to take
comfort in the fact
which i believe is not a fact which is a
false assumption i want you to
the other people have not had sex in
this van that's just not
that's it most couples who go camping
have sex with each other
i've never had you haven't been camping
with your wife before
you just said that at the top well you
may be right and you know what i i need
to get my own van
whoa okay i was okay with it you should
get your own van for
for other reasons we didn't we didn't we
didn't discuss this it just happened in
my mind i'm only discussing it with you
because i knew this is where it would
land
i just i think maybe what you should
realize at this point is that
um you have probably
had sex in many different places where
other people have had sex and most
likely can you say male 1
uh no because i think that you're i
think that we have to talk about this
directly at this point i think that the
analogy is fun
uh but i think that it may be making you
think incorrectly about it sometimes an
analogy can get
too vivid yeah like i have to wear a
postal outfit
i think that we need to now be using
literal terms
so next time you have sexual intercourse
with your wife
yeah in a place that is not your home
you need to assume that another couple
has also had sexual intercourse in that
place and that's fine and you need to be
okay with that
i i was i was okay enough with it to to
to finish the job not without taking a
water break though
it's totally unrelated and then i was
like man i hope
we're not close to other people like
when we camp other nights because i
don't want to be thinking are they over
there sorting their mail
right do they think that we're over here
sorting around well that doesn't matter
to me that
that's a more relevant question right
especially with the van doors open
because what i found is that there is a
sweet spot
i'm not talking about sorting mail i'm
talking about where you're
wherever you find a place to boondock
which is not
another word for sex this just means it
just means
it sounds like one though uh
bone docking complete initiating docking
sequence
uh well i mean because you think about
it yeah you dock
boone is a pretty good name for it and
docking is
the perfect burn docking in the
boondocks that's what i did man
wow boondocking uh boondocking just
means
camping dispersed camping is the
official term on like the national
forest websites
but to me there's a sweet spot you don't
want to be in an established campground
because you're too close to people
yeah but as i will explain thoroughly
and my
other people don't care no being too
remote
uh presents itself with a new set of
problems
there is a sweet spot in which you're
alone
yeah but you kind of know where that
other family is yeah and we knew there
was another
couple like the first place we went to
and that like we could
we could barely see them if we looked
through the trees in certain way like
i mean like over a mile away right you
feel like i had made contact with people
a conversation with yourself in my case
uh you can play your own music you're
not
thinking about like if you need to like
walk to the side of the campsite
and piss on a tree or something like
that you can do all this freely yeah
but so so obviously i wasn't thinking
about boondocking
or sorting the mail because i was alone
so the question for
for you would be
was that on your mind like could someone
be watching and does that
would that bother you well we had
already because we didn't want to shower
in the shower
like i said we showered out in the open
using the garden hose that had hot and
cold water spigot right there at the
back of the van
like we did like a full-on shower there
yeah like
shampoo i had my freaking loofah baby
you brought a loofah yeah or a loofah
okay all right
i took it i took an exfoliation
i know i don't have i don't bring i
don't have a loofah to bring
now we don't know why there was judgment
in this when you go
to uh uh i gotta get to my scary story
too so
we'll just just quickly answer this
do you go when you go to a hotel that is
uh like a high-rise in new york city for
instance
yeah and one of the walls is a window
yeah and it faces across to another
building that has a similar setup
yeah and you're in it the time to sort
the mail comes
do you close the windows or do you put
on a show
i think i don't know i
i honestly don't know i think i'm i
think it depends
on i don't know there's a lot more
variables than like what i actually see
out of the window and how close
it is well yeah so but if it's cl if if
if i can see other people walking around
and if they were nude i could see them
like i usually well if you turn off most
all the lights i leave the windows open
see i have not been able to be darker i
haven't been able to convince my wife of
this yet
but my personal philosophy in this
situation is
if i can look to an opposing building
and i can see that there's people
yeah but i could not identify them
without
you know a position they were in i could
identify the position
okay and i could tell okay there's a
long-haired man and a
woman or whatever or whatever you know
but
not hey there's a rhett having sex with
his wife yeah yeah without the
assistance of like some sort of
binoculars or something
uh i am on team open win
open window open curtain because but
when the lights are off
in the room no i'm team lights on open
window no you're not
i am light's off man
lights on okay all right that's okay
i want to see what's happening but then
you're encountering resistance from your
mate uh she is she's not completely
close to the idea
she also thinks that like
she also thinks that like everyone can
hear and see
everything she thinks that everyone else
on earth is superman
in terms of how well they can see in
here you know what i'm saying yeah i
mean you got to ease into it leave the
curtain open but turn the light off man
just you need just enough light to read
what the mail says so you can sort it
you got to know where it goes if i had
to choose between lights on or window
open i would choose lights on because i
i mean
i like a nice candle light or like no
i'm not i don't i don't mean like
fluorescence i'm talking about like the
bathroom light is on and i'm not talking
about like
commercial kitchen lighting i'm talking
about like
uh i want to be able to see everything
but
also if it's a little bit dim you know
everything is
you're both that much more flattering to
one another sure
yeah but completely dark no no not
completely i mean
ambient light i don't want it to be
fuzzy ambient lighting
it does not allow for anyone across a
skyscraper to watch you
but having people across the skyscraper
watch you can
in my thinking and never experienced it
could be an enhancement
just for every once in a while okay
i yeah all right i want to hear your
story though
it's not that i want to cut that
conversation short it says i don't have
anything to say
after that it's like okay you know and
i'm like
i'm gonna just thumbs up
well my favorite part about these
conversations is that after we have them
people tweet at my wife and then i get
home
and she's like what did you talk about
what were you talking about we
pre-recorded these
so long ago i don't remember
um so it was our this story happens and
it is not a story this is
a true event a matter of fact i wrote
down
what happened so i wouldn't forget any
of it and to lend credibility to it
i didn't want to i didn't want to forget
anything and i'll
you know christy christie had a more
direct experience with a key part of
this so i wanted to make sure that her
story came through correctly
and not in any way embellished this is
how
the things happened we had gotten pretty
good at camping by our last night
like i said we went outside of vegas we
were we were looking forward to
finding a campsite earlier and then also
leaving later the next morning like to
really be at a leisurely pace
and still be able to get home before i
have to return this thing at five
o'clock
so we went up into this
level canyon road it's actually
it's a road in the middle of nowhere on
the back side of that mountain range
that overlooks
las vegas you can't you can't see
anything i mean it took a long time to
get up there
once you're gonna once once you get on
that
road it goes for miles
up into this this picturesque valley
and then there's there's an occasional
gravel
pull off to the side with um where
people could camp
we saw a couple of people but the one i
was going for was way far
in there and um i we wanted cell service
so i went as far as we could go
we lost cell service then we came back
and i saw one campsite that was
up on this berm in the middle of this
valley this amazing
berm where we drove
off of it was actually a paved road did
i say that it was like it was asphalt
the main road through the thing so it
was like accessible
more accessible than other places but
then once you go off of that on the dirt
road
like i was like i'm gonna put it in four
wheel drive because i just don't know
like going over these rocks right it was
not a smooth road at all
it wasn't a gravel road it was
borderline
off-road off-roading right there but it
wasn't
far that we would we would go off the
paved road
we would go up this berm um
maybe 400 yards and there was a campsite
that had this amazing vista
on both sides we had cell service but i
looked and there was
down a little saddle further on the
off-roading
and back up and like 200 yards away
there was another
it dipped down and went back up and
there was another berm so i drove over
there
and it just wasn't flat enough i'd
learned that like if you don't park
flat you don't sleep flat and that's
it really compromises your ability did
they not give you the little blocks to
balance
no they weren't blocked i took those
with me those
proved to be i underestimated like
people are leaving reviews about like
the campsite is flat and i'm like i've
discovered it
for a tent that's really important but
when you have the van or you've got the
rooftop tent
i just bought like 30 bucks on amazon
these
blocks that you can stack in all these
different ways and i use them under the
wheels literally every single night to
get
under multiple wheels to get it exactly
it became this mission to get the 10
exactly because you sleep a lot better
if you're sliding especially with two
people when you're like smooshing
somebody yeah
um that's not good so we left that
outermost burn we came back 200 yards
down the saddle back
up to this other berm and then we set up
shop there
uh sun was still it was like four
o'clock
we had plenty of time to enjoy
everything uh
we had it was like 360 degree view you
cooking inside the van
no we're cooking on the there's a burner
in there but then we had
we cooked on top of the uh that propane
tank outside like we had a big
rectangular skillet we ate breakfast for
dinner that night
because we had it was our last night we
had eggs and bacon christie made the
bacon
she fried the bacon and it spelled link
she
she knows the weight of my heart wow
yeah pretty great huh
we're having a great time we're
listening to sea change
by beck that's a big pan or a small
bacon it's a
yeah the pan was this big okay um
and then the sun's going down and some
i think there is some smoke residue or
it it might have just been so hot the
ambient heat
it created this amazing effect on the
sunset it was like
literally the most amazing sunset we've
ever
we've ever seen like it was it was
wonderful we were having the time of our
lives
and then uh we we ate we ate dinner
as it was getting dark and then because
she made the dinner i was on dish duty
inside of the camper and she was sitting
outside
i think reading something by or like on
her phone because she had service
and um by this point it's it's dark
it's like nine o'clock okay
and i'm like finishing up washing the
dishes
and earlier in the day before it got
dark
we heard a car coming up the road and it
was again it was still light
and so i stepped out of the camper to
just let them know that like hey there's
two people here
and i'm gonna i'm gonna suss out these
people people coming up the dirt road
yeah coming up the dirt road and they
had to go
right beside our van
to then go down that little thing to go
to that next site that we decided not to
take
well really early on one guy along with
the rooftop tent went there he parked
and we're like oh man is he gonna say
he's if we and we can't shower there now
because he would see us
he stayed there for a few minutes then
he left later on yeah you can't be
crowding people man it's a freaking
desert there's all kinds later on it's
it's it's it's it's almost sunset
this other man and it looked like his
teenage daughter
came through and then they went up and
checked out the same spot
and then we're like watching and then
and we could see them
we could see and they got out of their
car
and they set up a tent and they stayed
so we were a little bit bummed but like
we were facing the other direction and
they were on the other side of the van
like i said 200 yards away on another
berm so we still felt like we had
pretty good privacy and then some went
down we ate our dinner
it's nine o'clock at night i'm inside
washing the dishes she's outside on her
phone
and all of a sudden i hear
gravel and i see like headlights hit
the side of our van and a car
is creeping up the
the dirt road coming right up to us and
like
i'm in there watching and the car comes
past
my field of view and stops where i can't
see
the car i can't see who's driving the
car
or anything i can just see the tail of
the car from where i was
washing the dishes but i could see
christy and she could see
this car of course because she was out
there in the open
and then the car stops right next to you
right next to the back of our van
and i hear a guy say to christy
are you selling any hot dogs
and christy sit and i
freeze and i'm like what the hell is
this guy
asking about hot dogs and i'm like i
literally freeze and i'm like just
listening because it was hard for me to
hear
but my instinct was just to listen so
let me let let me just
here's the exchange are you selling any
hot dogs
and then i hear christy say um
no we actually don't have any
and then the guy says i'm going around
getting people to vote
vote on my pictures to see which ones
they like best
and i'm still listening and then christy
goes
um no
no thank you we're not interested and
she was like really
had a friendly voice and then the guy
said
i just need you to vote on the photos uh
see i have him right here
and i can't see him and then christy
and you're still christie stood up
you're still at the in the kitchen
in the kitchen frozen like washing like
you got to be out there at this point in
retrospect i was trying to figure out
why it was i frightened was i frozen
with fear
was i being strategic i think all of
these were happening because
my initial thing was the strategic
hesitation
i was trying to assess the situ i was
i was freaked out oh i was like as you
should have i was like what the heck's
going on
like when the people came around earlier
i had come out
and show my face but my instincts told
me just sit back here christy
is gonna well i need to do whatever it
takes to de-escalate this situation
this guy seems strange very
little and uh i think i was just like
christy is going to politely get this
guy to drive
off if i go out there and like say
something i might say the wrong i had
this instinct that i was going to say
the wrong thing
and i will say you might escalate i had
had a couple
okay okay so i wasn't
i wasn't i i i was just trying to know
my limitations and i was like i might go
out there and i might be aggressive or i
might try to scare the guy and that and
they know how i can
that is your mo when you enter into
weird situations like
you come in pretty aggressive or pretty
strong and if and i'm not de-escalating
and if i had
yeah i i escalate things and if i've if
i've had a few i speak louder
and so i think i i didn't have enough
that i did i didn't know that about
myself so
my instinct told me christy's going to
de-escalate this
i'm going to stay back here and then
then i can assess what i need to do
when the time is right so
i mean he was like i'm i'm going around
getting people to vote to vote on
my pictures to see which ones they like
best and then christie's like
no thank you we're not interested and
then he said i just need you to vote on
the photo see i have him right here and
then christy told me that he holds
up like four by six photos it wasn't a
phone it was
literal photos he had printed out photos
and he was of course he's in the
driver's seat he's leaning over the
passenger seat
trying to lure christy close to the car
to show her the pictures how old
is this guy what does he look like
christy said it's very dark
again there's no moon we had we had
turned
most of our lights off you're way out
there we're way out there
yes and christie is like uh well
now we're just we're just wrapping up
dinner
and then she said she couldn't see his
face that well but it was just
it was one guy in the car and it was
like a it was a hatchback car
it could have been like a like a subaru
outback type thing
that could have gone on this off-roading
part
um but if you're in a car and you go
slow enough
you can you could navigate it and so it
was just a hatchback that's all we could
tell
he was he's leaning from the driver's
side so she can't really see his face
but it's just some white dude i mean she
couldn't describe him more than that
and then uh he's like she's like
we're just wrapping up dinner and so she
said
he's like okay and he throws his hand up
in the air like whatever
and then he slowly keeps going past us
to the other people down
into that thing and then up to those
next people
and at that moment that he drove away
christy you know
while still in the kitchen christy comes
in there and
she's visibly freaking out yeah
and i'm also freaking out and like our
eyes are so wide
and it was like we were like what just
happened is what we seem to be saying to
each
other without actually saying words and
uh i was just like she was like
was this guy trying to this guy was
trying to lure me to the car i was like
yeah i didn't know if i should go out
there if i should wait but it felt like
you were handling it
and i was like um i just you know i just
wanted him to go away and it seemed like
you were doing a good job of that she
was like
and i was thinking we got to get out of
here you know
he's going to these this guy is
unpredictable did you do
he may be unstable or a knife or
anything i wasn't thinking that at the
time i have one of those like
five-in-one tools that has a knife in it
i have a
giant knife yeah i like like i didn't
even think about the hunting knife
that's like 12 inches long and i kept it
in my tent every night just in case
trouble came yeah yeah well let me tell
you i got to rethink some things
to think think things through on another
level because at this point i'm thinking
in my mind
i know christy wants to get the hell out
of dodge and i'm also thinking he's got
to come back by
all right we knew that he had to come
back by us once he was done once
the the yes the dad and the daughter
were done judging the photos
yes or once he's done like killing and
eating them
there it's a dead end he has to come
back by us so we were freaking out that
we knew he
we knew he was coming back by also you
still got cell service did it hit you
that maybe you should call the police at
that point christy said
let's call the cops and i'm like let's
not let's not call the cops yet let's
not panic
and i just didn't feel like i
i don't know i just didn't want to call
the cops we can put a let's put a pin in
that
okay but i'm not saying that you
definitively should have called the guy
at that point christy was talking about
let's call the cops there was there was
a debate there's obvi
is there something not right about this
guy yeah there's several things not
right about this guy so
christy was like
i need to pack everything up so that
when he comes back through
we can be ready we can be in the van
locked up
and we can if we need to leave we can
just leave
so i was like listen christy and we
turned off all the lights in the van
so that we could see through our little
window we watched him drive
down there to those other people with
all of our lights on we couldn't see him
that well
so we like how easy is it to pack up we
doused
everything and then i was like christy
you look out this window and you keep
your eyes glued to this guy if he starts
coming back you let me know
while you don't don't take your eyes off
of his car lights
i'm gonna get everything cleaned up and
then i i went out there and i got
the the propane tank had just propane
burner had just
cooled down enough to put it in the car
the propane tank
our chairs the cooler i'm scrambling
putting everything away
in the pitch dark without any lights on
and then i put everything back in
and i come back in and she's like he's
still
there yeah i mean he's got a lot of
photos to go he's still there i don't
you know did he did he kill both of them
i don't know you know what's he doing is
he putting on their skin
as a suit you know i don't know what's
happening but
i'm thinking if we and i asked chris
like
if we're watching a movie of us right
now
what would we be saying to our
characters
get the hell out of here yeah but in the
movie that you would definitely have
judged the photos
because of what i mean that's what what
would be more fun for a plot
oh really so yeah yeah christie would
have christie did stand up i think
but she did not walk towards the man
with the photos
yeah we knew he was coming back and
we're like i don't want to be i don't
want to i don't want to be the people in
the movie that i'm going to be angry at
we need to be ready to leave so
like we locked up the van we locked up
everything and then
all of a sudden that the car starts
moving and it starts creeping back and
because of the terrain it had to go so
slow
and it went down in that berm and it
came up
and we're looking at the back two
windows of the van where he would drive
right
past us and he drives
and he gets comes right up to the van
and then he keeps going
slowly and he goes down below the van
and he gets back to the paved road and
we can still see him and he stops there
at the paved road and he doesn't he has
to turn right or left
he doesn't turn anywhere he sits there
for a
long time and i'm like how long it felt
like 10 minutes
like he was like i don't know is he
blocking our only exit
like we're sit we're cowering in this
van locked up
and then he turns left and we like watch
him go
down into the canyon and then we watch
him go up
on another berm where a long ways away
we saw that there was another camper and
it's like
ah she's like we need to get out of here
and it was like she was like
you've you
you you can't drive it's like you don't
want to get a dui
you know her she didn't want her first
experience driving the sprinter van
to being off-road yeah off-road so then
it's like you just need to like
you just need to just take some time how
long do you think it's going to take you
before you feel like you can drive and
i'm like ah
an hour and then like we're just sitting
there in the dark
freaked out you can see you can still
you can kind of see where he went i see
that he went to another site
and then like over 20 minutes of
processing this i'm like you know what
it's a paved road down the middle of
this thing this guy's a little off
but i bet you he comes up in here and
tries to sell
his pictures to campers and i'm like
christy
he he said i'm not trying to sell you
anything i just want you to vote on my
pictures but then when you said i like
this one best i'm voting for this one he
would say
i'll sell it to you for five dollars
because it was like pictures of like
nature
so well pictures of him like posing yeah
yeah which would have been
especially weird it wasn't like you and
like a new york city
exhibition right yeah in your bedroom so
i'm like this guy is just a strange guy
who likes to sell his pictures to
like campers in the pitch black of night
yeah not a great strategy um and she's
like well
i would feel better if we went and
talked to that other couple and i'm like
if we drive up there
there's no place to turn around because
of where they parked i can't turn this
van around
that's probably why it took him so long
up there because he couldn't turn his
car around
and i'm trying you know i'm like i'm
getting my wits about me now i'm not
freaking out as much and i'm trying to
de-escalate how
scared christie is and i'm like and then
we start so we start
walking down into the ravine
up to where this other camping group is
the dad and the daughter and we get
halfway there and like i you can hear
someone's on a laptop
or like watching a show or something but
then it's like it's so dark out there
and i just had a headlamp and i was like
we're gonna freak them out by going up
there and we just
we got too scared to walk up to them and
we turned around and walked back and we
were like
we're like i'm scared we were like
laughing chrissy had not had anything by
the way she was just
like she's just predisposed to be
freaked out by this stuff and she
doesn't like to drive off-road
which stuck us in this middle ground
where like huddled back at the van
afraid this guy's gonna come back
and i'm like listen this is fine she was
i really would feel better if we talked
to those other people so we walked out
there again
did you make it this time we get halfway
and we get scared again and we come back
hold on you're scared i don't know we
were just so freaked out that we didn't
want to go
scared of freaking them out we were
scared of freaking we were scared of
freaking them out what if what if
after all this like that guy has a knife
or a gun and like he's trying to protect
his daughter and we're the ones who get
caught in the crossfire or something
because we freaked him out and we were
going to yell at him and then it's like
you don't want to yell
hey we want to talk to you about that
guy that tried to get you to judge the
photos
we go back and i'm like listen
everything is fine we're locked up
in this and you sleep inside the van we
sleep inside the van
it's locked up
i um so we
we got we got we got calm we're like
we're just going to chill out here
and then we're like you know what we're
here i mean we're just bedding down for
the night
i got some mail hmm this is not a great
time you can sort some out you know what
surprisingly enough there was enough
mail on both sides to sort
that it actually well it actually
you know sometimes when you clean up it
gives you a sense of control
i think sometimes sorting the mail gives
you a sense of um
release well it's like a gorilla when a
gorilla is
trying to um express diamonds dominate
another gorilla gets an erection and
shows it
yeah yeah and it's actually way smaller
than you would expect because
because you would know that like anyone
who's really scared can't get an
erection
right if they're even not even just a
gorilla like i'm talking about me
so being able to get an erection and use
it yeah
is actually the ultimate show that we
were relaxed
we were completely right we were over in
fact come on back let me buy some of
your photos
and then uh so then i was feeling pretty
good
and we were like getting getting
everything like i got i probably got a
drink of water
and i got it you did and it's like
all of a sudden the sliding door
on the van
begins to open now it's a big
electric sliding door so it's like you
pull the handle and then it like
goes out and then it slowly and there
was dirt so it took a while for it to
open
i did not ha the keys were up in the
front where i had locked the van
chrissy didn't have them no we didn't
touch any buttons that would have opened
the door
100 we did not do anything to open the
door but here we are
the door is opening and i'm standing
there
looking out the door as it's opening
waiting to see this guy standing there
it scared the [ __ ] out of me
and also christy like like she literally
had to go to the bathroom once we found
out there was no one standing there
i don't know why the door opened but
there was my theory is there's some sort
of voice command that connects to like
the entertainment system you didn't know
about the voice
and i don't think that the voice can
sometimes it would come on kind of like
hey when you say hey siri so it's
but i don't have any proof that that
would actually work with the van maybe
we
it wasn't locked all the way and when i
said you said like
open no i was i did not want the door to
open
i'm so open right now there was nothing
there was nothing on the other side of
that
van door except blackness it was so dark
it scared me but you you expected the
guy to be standing there with two photos
yeah he wasn't there which one do you
like just tell me
and then christy at this point christy
wasn't freaking out and i was like i
think it was the voice
thing because something lit up on the
entertainment console
i was lying and so she was fine
and she wasn't freaking out about it so
then i closed the door back and then i
made sure everything was locked
and then we laid back down in the bed
and christy kept looking at those
she was looking through the window but
like i rolled over and went to sleep
i don't know how long i was asleep
christy said i was snoring but she was
wide awake and looking out the window
and then what i woke up to was
christy grabbing my thigh this story is
still going yes
she grabbed my thigh and it
it was it was probably 10 30 at this
point
i woke up out of asleep and like eyes
wide open
headlights shining through the back of
the van
in my face oh my gosh did you
immediately recognize the same
headlights
and i couldn't see because those
headlights and then the car
is creeping towards us and and coming
right up to our van
and then it slowly goes
by and it's the same car
it's a hatchback i will say for a fact
it's a hatchback car
and it keeps going by and we are
freaking out
i mean every every time that we've been
freaking out this whole time with all
the lights
nuts christy and i've been whispering to
each other we haven't been talking a
loud voice
we've been like whispering like what do
we do and it was like oh [ __ ] i think
that's
i i don't think it's the same car i'm
like telling christy i'm like that's a
different car it's boxier
yeah i'm lying right i'm thinking this
is the same freaking car
this is picture man and he goes by us
he knows it's a dead end he goes down
into that
saddle and then i can barely see his car
stop brake lights he doesn't go up to
the to those people
he's he his car stops down in the in the
bottom
100 yards from us and 100 yards from
them
and then all of a sudden the lights in
the car go off
and i'm waiting for the interior i'm
waiting for the interior light to come
on when the car door opens
they don't it doesn't he's bedding down
it's totally black
and then we just sit there for a long
time just watching to see if there's any
signs of this guy getting out of his car
because i'm like
and then i'm like i sit up and i'm like
just keep watching
i'm getting in the driver's seat and
we're getting the hell out of here
and i and i got in the driver's seat and
i backed that puppy up and we drove
out of there because the guy was just
there
at any moment he could have got out of
the car walked up there and made his
skin into a suit
my skin into his shoes you have no
choice now and so we drove down
like to the end of the road where we
pulled off the main road and we were
still in a place where we just
parked over there we saw someone else
camping we camped kind of near them we
just parked
and we felt much better and we slept
that night got up the next morning but i
wanted to go
walk ride back up there and see if
anybody was still up there
but because what about the dad and the
daughter
well they they were alive the first time
he left
and then the second time he didn't go
back up there but like
he he might he might have blocked them
in
we that's the scariest that's the
scariest i've ever been
and it was like multiple freaking parts
to it
and maybe we should call the ranger even
now
and tell them hey heads up there's
something to do with pictures if there's
a you know
i don't have much of a description but
maybe maybe this is what's happening
with this guy
maybe um years ago
he made a deal with the devil of sorts
okay
and now every night he has
a piece of sweat he has to get someone
to buy one of his photos or else he
turns into a pumpkin
and i think what happened is is that
either he succeeded or he didn't
and he goes back to that spot and if you
had a stuck around until midnight you
would have seen him turn into a pumpkin
what do you think really happened though
i think the guy was a little off but he
was just trying to make scratch
selling these pictures of nature and i
i'm dying to know what he said to those
people but i was too scared to walk up
there and i'm mad at myself and what did
they
did they see him coming up because i
mean if they were freaked out
then they see this guy come down and
stop at the bottom of the ravine do you
think that they knew that he was there
yeah they they definitely would have
seen him
and he's on the road yeah so they can't
get around him
yeah i did a bad thing didn't i
we abandoned these those people got
boxed in by this guy who knows
what you and this this just happened two
nights ago you might need to look at the
news
and it might be like father and daughter
murdered by craig's photo man
outside of las vegas and if that
happened while other couple sorts of
mail
in the closed vicinity and now you've
told your whole story
and which includes well we saw him we
got a little bit scared we had sex
and then we left no he came back
you came back at this point i don't you
don't really need an alibi because you
but
i mean you definitely are an
accomplished to this i just i don't like
calling the cops because i didn't want
to i didn't want to like trouble them
they got things to worry about
other than that you know it's like and i
couldn't describe my exact location
i was like well we're up this canyon
road and
we still have cell service so we're not
too far in but we're not
we're really far in and it's one of
those situations and i'm not saying i
would
i don't think i would have uh i would
have acted any differently
but it's one of those things that you
wish you could go back and the moment
that he shows up
you could just say something like hey
bro let's talk about this
you understand what you're doing is very
weird and threatening it's dark we're
out here in the middle of nowhere
you're asking these weird questions
about selling hot dogs and then asking
us to judge your photos
this makes my wife and i feel unsafe oh
well in that case let me shoot you in
the face and turn your skin into a suit
i don't think that would happen i think
the reaction would be oh you're right
i'm not crazy anymore no no they'd still
be crazy but you would at least say
so dude get it go away or i'm going to
call the police
i i'm i'm not saying i would have done
that going in
but if this ever happens to me to me now
that's what i'm going to do
i i feel more prepared now i would have
i would have gone out there and i would
have said something here's the thing
that i've learned
whenever you're out there camping and
there are people going by like when that
when that dad and daughter went by i
probably would have waved them down
and had a conversation because that way
it's like i have an assessment of who
these people are on this next berm
and then i would have confidence if i
needed to if i needed help
or if i needed to check on them i i know
i have confidence that
i know who they are that was part of why
i was scared to go over there because i
didn't
i don't know that it was a dad daughter
it was like
it was a weird age difference yeah so
you know
maybe that maybe that's what they do i
don't know it's
you know maybe this maybe the photo
person was with them
and they spent a lot of time there and
they were like they're a team huh it's
not a very effective plan
yeah they need to work on their strategy
i don't know what the ending
is i could get better at being ready for
this type of thing and then
again not escalating it the the main
thing is like
after i was like as it was happening i
was like okay
if we don't die this is the end of me
and christy ever going camping again
and i was mad yeah like i ruined it but
you know what
she actually took it in stride with our
entire trip and all the other
things that happened and at least it
happened last night we had a positive
experience
that happened the first night every so
many positive experiences that it that
this
this scary thing did not outweigh it
so you know just to kind of shut this
down
in a positive place i'm not saying i'm
definitely going to buy one of these
off-road sprinter van outfits because
i've got three kids and there's a lot of
problems associated with that
space was of a premium let me tell you
how
many people could you comfortably take
on a trip um
we could have brought lando and there's
one place that could lay out where he
could sleep in a separate bed
but also but you could do a rooftop tent
or just set up a tent
take a tent yeah because my rooftop
tenant is rated for three people but
they
they would be very small people yeah so
i think i could either have jesse or one
of the kids and so i i was like i'll
just take an extra ten put her on the
ground
if that guy would have been on the other
side of that sliding door
like i have no explanation for why it
opened but
that i've never been so scared that's
why you gotta have a knife man
that's why i was yeah like and i needed
to have that
knife in my hand i had bear spray had a
bull horn
and a giant knife i yeah i
i've never been more scared than at that
moment because like
i i just remember the feeling of peering
over into the darkness as the door
it could not have opened slower and i
just
knew that he was just going to be
standing there yeah
you know we're not prepared for that
kind of thing like because we live in
such a controlled
civilized yeah society at this point and
you go back
in several hun several thousand years
first of all you wouldn't be in a van
because they didn't exist
but if you had been in a van and the
door opened you would be immediately
like in an aggressive
like you would have been so ready like
you would have been punched in the air
you know this is what i looked like
right yeah you were totally you were
petrified man like this i was like
sticking my neck out to be chopped
we've lost the ability to just take life
by the horns man
yeah we've been coddled yeah we should
all be
we should have knives i might have so
many knives
we should have throwing knives we should
have
claw like gloves you realize
so you're saying that link neil should
go into the woods
cosplaying as wolverine yeah like is
that a good idea i mean you might hurt
yourself and others but you'll also
protect yourself
just the first night i couldn't figure
out the freaking van this is another
point of reference like
we were bend down for the night and i'm
like i can't get the
the cab lights to turn off in the front
of the cab i can't get him to turn off
i was pushing buttons everywhere i
accidentally pressed the sos
button on the mercedes that's a problem
and all of a sudden
i heard it hello i heard a number i
heard it
it's ringing yeah and i'm pushing
buttons and i can't get it to stop well
they'll ask you if it's a true emergency
and then all of a sudden i'm like
they're like hello is this an emergency
and i was like
um no i'm one of the 98 of the people
who accidentally pressed this button
that you talked to
all night long now what i said was he
said hello
is this an emergency and i said no but
can you help me with a technical issue
no you did and she said no uh
no this is for emergency uses only i'm
like okay well i didn't even mean to
call you
i just hit the number by but hit the
button by accident and she hung up
and then i ended up pressing the sos
button three more times by accident
trying to figure out how to turn the
the lights off but she never answered
again i got blocked cried wolf
and then i got in bed i'm like i'm sorry
christy the cab lights are going to be
on
it's going to be ambient and then she's
like
i'm scared this is a first night she
said i'm scared sleeping with the doors
open on the back of the van
so i was like i went around walked
outside closed the doors because that's
how you have to close them and then as i
was walking back i was like
that's why the doors are open that's why
the damn lights were
on so then i closed all the doors and i
hit the lock button
and the van locked and all the lights
went off and that's how i know
that i don't know how that door opened
for the creepy guy to not be there
because
i had figured it out but everything was
so hard to figure can you have the doors
open and the lights off
surely you can you can't hit the lock
button
if you hit the lock button the lights
stay on to let you know that you didn't
actually lock your van because there's
doors gaped open got it yeah
so you have to learn to speak the van's
language yeah maybe i'll get one
maybe not but i definitely have
an appreciation for going out into
nature and just like
and bringing my mail i don't know if i
ever want to bring my kids honestly
maybe just one kid at a time type of
thing if i have this van i can do
smaller trips too it doesn't have to
always be
i'm trying to talk you into talking me
into this um you can come
me and you can take the van yeah but we
gotta share a bed right uh i will have a
different
what put a rooftop tint on it you can
put a rooftop tent on the van
yeah that'll be way up there you're used
to it
um it's true you definitely should do it
man i
i that may have been the scariest i've
ever been period
i mean i haven't had anything that
legitimately
i as i'll share in my my episode i'm
just trying to get people to vote on my
pictures
lots of first of all i thought you're
gonna say i'm just trying to get people
to vote i was like no no
that's what i thought i was like this
guy in the middle of nowhere you're
trying to get out the vote
yeah man whatever it takes that's what i
every vote counts i was so i was
nevada's a swing state everything he
said was so strange
that i was just frozen in fear and and
lack of assertiveness um but christie
handed herself like a master
now here's the thing my wife would be my
wife would be really mad at me
if i had behaved like you did at the
beginning i was surprised christy wasn't
mad at me because
because i think i deserve it there was
this one there's this one time
that she never lets me live this down
there's this one time we were in chapel
hill
been married for like a year yeah and
there was a
a homeless man who was aggressive and
uh kind of like kind of coming
at us and you pushed her i know i didn't
push her into it
take her not me what if that's what i
actually think it's a small one
um i had seen this guy before and he was
he would get in people's faces and you
know yeah yeah
most of the time the vast majority of
the time
uh if a person in this situation gets
aggressive it's all talk
you know it's all bark no bite right um
so we're just walking along and she
is on the side that he's and he kind of
comes at us
and i just sort of looked at him and
just kept walking
unthreat did but i didn't get in front
of her
and i didn't bow up to the guy because
in my mind this guy's
just a little bit nuts he does this kind
of aggressive thing when he comes up to
you and then
you just walk by but for our entire
marriage she has held that against me
that i you know her in her mind i pushed
her to this guy
and um so now i i have this
conscious thing where it's just like if
we're in a situation where someone is
threatening i've got to like
i've got to like insert myself but i
haven't and i have the opportunity
because
remember that age-old the story of
christie was pregnant and the guy
yeah right and the f the guy with the
football you tend to come in a little
bit what are you doing
yeah i you know i i got to swing the
pendulum back
all right let me shut this down i need
to make a quick wreck it's my turn to
make a wreck
um on a let's see
not the last but the ama before that the
mythical society ama we do every month
uh some somebody asked what i was
listening to
and i told them what we were listening
to and make it a recommendation
zephaniah
this guy channels merle haggard and he's
and he's like i mean i'm not telling you
anything you don't know because we
discovered this guy
uh he channels merle haggard on these
like these
vintage country music tracks he's out of
brooklyn it's pretty phenomenal
um my favorite song we planned to have
it all
it's like an early 80s mural he usually
goes like
some of the earlier mural but you know
we really like that early 80s merle not
the like
early 70s merle we love it but that's
our sweet spot
we plan to have it all is the song that
i'm recommending
by zephaniah o'hara off the album
listening to the music
oh man i gotta i gotta get out of this
sweatshirt i just been sweating too much
uh and if you're out there and you're
listening to this
podcast and and you have a tendency to
just approach people
just outside of vegas in the dark to get
them to buy
or maybe just vote on your photos
just understand or buy people's hot dogs
that's your opening line um this is not
a good strategy
for selling your photos you've you
frightened
you frightened at least one family that
night
and you're on the verge of being
reported
it hasn't happened yet though it hasn't
happened yet
just know probably next time some the
next person you approach in this way
will probably
call the authorities or stab you and if
that person is me both those things i
guess will happen because now i'm ready
for it
yeah hashtag here biscuits
we'll hear about rhett's amazing
solitary experience
next time yeah that i didn't run into
that guy spoiler alert
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left
and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best